hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled
visualization and analysis of high
parameter scitov data
with fcs express in record time i'm
xavier gutierrez of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by fluidize
now let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
i now present today's speaker dr david
novo
president of de novo software for a
complete biography on dr
novo please visit the biography tab at
the top of your screen
dr novo you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for the kind introduction and
um
thank you for inviting me to speak today
at the fluidim infectious disease and
oncology virtual summit
uh my name is dave novo i'm the
president of de novo software
and i'm going to spend a few minutes of
your time today
introducing you to fcs express
our flow and image cytometry data
analysis software
and showing some really amazing examples
of how you can use fcs express
to speed up and visualize your
analysis of site off data
i'm really pleased to announce that
um going forward uh fluidime
is going to be providing a copy of
fcs express a one year license
uh at no charge to all um customers who
purchase a new
helios instrument so that's really great
everybody will have
a at least a copy a single copy of xps
express
and with that we're going to be
providing all sorts of
templates and tools and resources to
really
simplify and enhance on the ability the
data the analysis of the data from
the helios instrument um a little bit of
a background for
anybody who's never heard of us before
uh de nopa software has been producing
cytometry analysis tools um for
about 20 years now um we have a team
around the world of
support staff and
to assist everybody in using and
learning the software
and fcs express is used
in a huge array of settings from
academic settings to biopharma settings
to
clinical lab settings to contract
research organizations
so we have a whole suite of
functionality that supports
support both validated research as well
as academic
research and can help uh customers no
matter what field they're in
as i'm going to show you later one of
the unique things about fcs express
is that it's not only a flow cytometry
analysis tool like what you're used to
in terms of getting plots and gates it
also helps you get your final package
and your final results
and then those are generally more these
days than just a bunch of pictures of
plots
and gates and we provide all those tools
fcs express is modeled off of microsoft
office
so particularly microsoft powerpoint
so you already know how to use it if you
know how to use powerpoint it's
very very simple to use and again
our key difference is that fcs express
tries to provide a tool
that you can get your complete results
in a single package
normally your flow data analysis
involves you
doing your primary flow analysis in your
flow software
and then from your flow software you go
to prism or you go to excel
and then from x or you go to r and then
from prism to excel to r you go to
powerpoint or you go to illustrator
um and you have to go through three or
four different software packages
in order to get the final result that
you're going to report to somebody
whereas as we'll show in the examples
that
later on in the presentation that can be
done all
right within fcs express itself so it
dramatically speeds up your time
to get your final results fcs express
has a lot of really key features
that are really really helpful for
particularly fluidized customers using
high dimensional data from the helios
i'm going to show a lot about you can
see integrated spreadsheets and graphing
where you can actually combine results
together from multiple tubes or multiple
samples and immediately get
uh bar charts and pie charts and
everything
updating as you move your gates um you
get publishing
publication quality graphics right
within the software
all in an easy microsoft office like
interface
and we have a whole suite of high
dimensional analysis tools and more
coming
all the time to support the cutting edge
data analysis that people need
again right within this very simple
microsoft office like
framework um you can see that we have
quite a few
uh transformations already available and
other ones are going to be
launched within the next couple of
months
again we're going to be building and
i'll be showing an example of pre-built
templates for common fluidized kits
and assays
and also you know again in an easy to
use
framework where you can actually both do
high dimensional data analysis and dot
plots and heat maps and
disney and all sorts of stuff but again
the little things like for example
simplified access labeling
you can very easily change any
formatting of your plots including the
axis labels
chain dot colors change dot sizes change
anything about the look and feel of the
plots that you want
in addition to of course very very
sophisticated analysis
um so you know in summary this is going
to be a really brief presentation
um you know again our focus is to help
you get your results
quickly and get a wide variety of
results not just a bunch of dot plots
and a bunch of histograms
but the actual results that you can
report in your lab meeting
and give to publications and use for
posters
quickly and easily
if you want more information after the
presentation please feel free to go to
our website at www.danovasoftware.com
we have dozens and dozens of videos
and tutorials and resources to get
started
and you can also of course grab a free
30-day demo
um and give it a try on your own it
already works with
the current demo works with data from
your helios so you can already
load it up and give it a try okay so i'm
gonna use the last few minutes of the
presentation to kind of give an overview
of an actual very commonly used assay
um that is commonly used uh with the
helios data and
uh from the instrument and that's an
example of the max par
layout or the max bar um
kit and you can see here so i've
switched over
uh quickly and this is a view of fcs
express
um you can see that it actually looks
like microsoft powerpoint we have very
familiar ribbon
we have an insert tab where you can
insert all
of the various types of plots that you
need
we have a gating tab we have batch
processing tab we have formatting tab
so everything works in a very very
familiar microsoft office environment
um so this layout is already so fcs
express is really great because it's
both
optimized for sort of free form data
analysis where you don't really know
what you're doing
and you just want to look at random
plots and random gates
but if you've already got a defined
analysis strategy
fcs express really can help you out as
well so you can see here
that this particular analysis has 18
pages
already pre uh pre-made you can see that
there are different pages for
the different subsets that you're used
to analyzing with the max par layout
so um how you get your data
into the layout is very very easy even
though there's 18 pages and
dozens and dozens and dozens of plots
all you have to do to get your data in
is add files to our data list that you
can see i'm working with over here
and i'm going to add two sets of data
as we all know the max part
template is an eight to panel so i'm
going to add 16 files to here
and you can see that what it did is it
load not only did it load the data
it also is placing the data
in all of the pages across all 18 pages
wherever it's supposed to go
so the plots for neutrophils and the
eosinophils went on page two
the clean up the plots for the cleanup
from tube one
went on this first page the plots for b
cell subsets went on the third page
etc so you can very very easily you saw
just within a few seconds
load up a whole set of data they're all
gated the statistics are all analyzed
um and i'll show some of the features of
this template in a little bit uh you can
very easily switch between
panels so for instance if i simply click
on this one over here
i'm actually going to jump to the first
set of eight tubes
and you can see that it loads up a whole
new set of data
and changes the analysis quite quickly
there seems to be a bit
of a delay because of the go to meeting
um but you can see that it switched to
the first set of tubes which are now
blue
and i'll go back again to the second set
of tubes and
you can see that it's switched again
okay
so i'm going to just use this analysis
layout to show some examples of
different things you can do
again in this very brief presentation
there's not a lot of time to get into
detail but
i do want to point out that there is a
lot of
gates this layout has tons and tons of
gates available to it you can see here
as an example
all the gates are already pre-made and
placed in a default position for you
generally where they're supposed to go
and of course as you move your gates
around you can see that the plots are
all updating
in real time to reflect your new gated
populations
okay so all the plots update in real
time all the statistics
update in real time as you're dragging
your gates around even on a complicated
layout like this
okay so you can see that there are tons
of plots these are all your primary flow
plots that you're used to
from your software and you can do
all the types of plotting all the types
of gating
density plots contour plots histograms
back gating everything you're used to
for primary flow analysis you can do in
fcs express so i'm not going to
focus on that for now i want to show you
some of the
novel features so if i jump to one of
the later pages for example
you can see here is actually a summary
of all of the
a lot of the cell populations within the
given
samples and you can see that
what we have here is comparing our two
different treatments s1 and s2
and the different uh cell subsets and
the percentages between them
and you can see at the top of the page
we actually calculate
in real time a p value showing the
statistical
difference between the s1 and s2
populations
across that um across that particular
gate or across that particular cell type
that we're looking at
these all update in real time as you're
moving your gates around so if i would
go to some of the other pages and move
the gates these would be updated as soon
as i got back
and i wanted to just point out that one
of this is made possible by one of the
really innovative features of fcs
express that being our integrated
spreadsheets
so you can see here that this actually
what i'm clicking in
is a spreadsheet these values in the
spreadsheet are not hard
coded they are actually statistics that
are linked to the various plots and
gates and quadrants
and whatever you're used to and they
update based on those
so these guys here are just statistics
that are pulled in from various places
in the analysis
but if i click in this cell mean s1 you
can see that
you actually can enter excel formulas
and average out the results of all of
these four
populations okay so you can combine
all the excel formulas that you're used
to with live
updating statistics that are updating as
your analysis changes
so this particular analysis for example
has
has
whoops sorry i jumped to the wrong page
you can see in this template that we
have
the average and we have the standard
deviation
formulas that we're calculating from our
samples
but just to show that we actually
support a wide
array all of the formulas that you
expect from excel
you can see a huge list of statistical
formulas
math and trigonometry formulas lookup
and reference formulas date and time
formulas logical formulas so you can do
if then
else so all of the complex analysis that
you
um can do with with excel you can all do
it within fcs express
except you can do it on all of your
primary flow data
all of your gated statistics that are
updating in real time
as you move your gates okay and i can
show that as a quick example i think on
this page
you see here that there's this
eosinophil bar plot and as i move my
eosinophil gate around
you can see that the bars and the bar
plots and the p values
and everything is updating in real time
as i move my gates around
okay so we support a lot of these plots
for pie charts bar
charts statistical regression charts a
lot of different things
again all have the um ability to
combine data from different samples in
novel ways and let you visualize them
um the last thing i wanted to show you
also is a example of how easy it is to
perform high dimensional data analysis
in fcs express
so one of the more common
statistical tools or visualization tools
that are used um
in this days is tisney and i just want
to show you how easy it is to apply a
disney analysis to your data
so you see i clicked here on the
transformation window and i already had
created a disney transformation and i'm
going to select which parameters i want
to participate in my disney
and i've already selected that i want my
disney to be based on cd19 cd4 cd8
cd6 cd45r0 and cd45ra
and so the only thing i actually have to
do to calculate the disney is simply
drag this disney onto my plot
and as with any disney it takes a second
or two to do the calculations so
it's done and now when i switch to
disney x
or tis and versus disney y
then you can see here is my disney plot
that i've generated from my data
and then if i quickly want to see all of
the parameters
we have a special plot and i'm going to
say
you know what i want to see
i want to see my disney plot colored on
these parameters
i can actually very quickly and now it's
got
each plot is colored based on a
different parameter
and if i want to format that data for
example
all of them together and potentially
show
a legend to see what um
what marker it's being is each plot is
using
i'm going to turn on the legend and you
see the plots update in real time to
show
the legend and i'm going to choose to
put the legend on the bottom
and you can see that right away now all
of my plots
quickly have a legend showing which
marker they're colored by
and showing that is the disney plot
colored by that particular marker
in that particular plot
okay so this was a very very brief
introduction
um and i don't want to exceed my time
here
um so i do want to thank the organizers
for letting me present
today um if you do have any questions at
all about what you've seen
please either contact your fluidim
representative or once again
just shoot an email to support
lenovosoftware.com
i'll make that big for you so you can
see it
[Music]
and we'll be glad to answer any
questions
that you have okay
thank you very much
a big thank you to dr novo for that
informative presentation
unfortunately dr nova cannot join us for
live q a today
however sean burke will be answering
questions on behalf of dr novo
welcome sean uh we will now start the q
a portion of the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now just click the ask
a question box
located on the far left of your screen
let's get started our first question
is going to be is fcs
express21 part 11 compliant
yeah and uh thanks again for uh having
us here and and hosting the presentation
today i'm happy to take that question
so fcs express does have the ability
to enable 21 part 11 compliant features
in the software
so the version of fcs express that comes
with the fluidim instruments will not
have this enabled
however you can contact our team at
support denovosoftware.com to get more
information about that
and essentially the way that fcs express
handles that is
by adding on a security and logging
functionality
so the security functionality allows
folks to restrict access to various
functions
to particular users and groups of users
as well as allowing electronic signature
type capability
and the other half of that is what we
call logging
which is also referred to as audit
trails and these logging and auto trails
is a system that allows you to track
every
change that you make to every single
layout so if you load data
if you move a text box if you move a
gate all that sort of information is
tracked so when you have these
additional add-ons enabled for the
software
it can help you conform with government
regulations such as 21 cfr part 11.
so again you can contact us at support
the nuvosoftware.com if you have any
questions about that
as a follow-up we can get you some more
information there
great and are more algorithms for high
dimensional data reduction planned
yeah absolutely and i know uh dave
alluded to that
that uh you know many more of these
things are coming down the line
so just in the next few months probably
by the end of the summer we're going to
have
a brand new pipelines tool in fcs
express that's going to allow you
to not just work with tizzy and spade
it's going to allow you to work with
tools like
umap and som some other kind of
familiar ones that are on the market and
it's also going to allow you to
customize these pipelines with down
sampling steps up sampling steps
to hopefully help you come up with new
algorithms on your own without having to
have any sort of programming or r
scripting knowledge
it's all through a pretty easy to use
interface directly in the software
and can i add more users or licenses to
my free one-year license
yeah so the the licenses that are going
to be coming with the flu dime
instruments
are what we call internet dongle
licenses
and essentially what that allows folks
to do is
install the software on as many
computers as they want
and one person at a time can use that
license
it means that you can set up 10 users 20
users 100 on that license but one person
at a time can use it
so you do have a lot of flexibility even
with the license
that comes with the software to put it
on as many computers as you want
however if you do need simultaneous
access you need two
three four people analyzing data at the
same time
we can enable that all you have to do is
contact our team at support
and you know for whatever the cost is we
can add those
additional users to the license and then
you can have a multi-user license at any
time
um so a question here are p values
adjusted for multiple testing
yes i think that that question probably
goes back to
the bar plots and the box and whisker
plots
that dave novo was showing during the
presentation
so uh the way that the p-values work in
fcs express
is just like you would work in a
spreadsheet in microsoft excel
so whatever data that you have in that
spreadsheet
is going to be what the p-values are are
based off of
so in the example that was being shown
it was two sets
of um i believe four tubes
each that were being compared to each
other so if you have multiple sets you
can either use the data list the kind of
move
between them you can add additional sets
of data
so really the way to think about it is
whatever you might do in microsoft excel
whatever you might do
in a tool like prism you can do that
same thing in fcs express you just have
to have the data loaded into the layout
and when you do that not only can you
you know compare
against multiple testings you get that
live
updating of gates or live updating of
statistics
as you move gates and you change data
files around
and why use fcs express with maxpar
if analysis can be done automatically
with path setter
yes i mean there's there's a lot of
advantages to using fcs express
i know from what i've seen past setter
does some really great things i'm sure
it has some you know really great
functionality that you want to use i
mean there's no reason
to not use path setter for for certain
things but where fcs express really
excels
is getting you those results very
quickly and very easily
through you know some of these
predefined templates that we have
we can see the changes that are being
made to the downstream
final results as gates update in real
time which is pretty nice
and also one thing we didn't really put
a lot of focus on just for the interest
of time is that when you're ready to get
those results out
whether it needs to go out to powerpoint
to pdf to high resolution images
fcs express has some very quick and easy
export tools
so if you needed to export some of your
disney plots and some of that
reported information to say powerpoint
you can literally click a button and
that data will be exported in whatever
resolution you want
so imagine you know you're going to a
conference um you know a real conference
one day we'll we'll be able to get back
and do that pretty soon which will be
pretty fun
uh but if you need a 300 dpi image for
your poster
well you can just set that in fcs
express you can hit the export button
and that's what we kind of refer to as a
final result right having that
uh graphic that's up there for your
poster at a presentation having that
graphic
that's ready to be sent off to the
publisher those are the things that fcs
express can
really help you with so again i think
pathsiter is a really great tool i think
fcs express can complement it
in a lot of ways when it comes to the
downstream and
final results that we get out
all right and looks like we're gonna
have time for one more question here
um can gating analysis be automated
or do they need to be adjusted manually
from sample to sample
yeah it's a great question so so right
now there is no um
i guess what we call automatic gating in
fcs
express however we do have uh
and we will be having more of these are
kind of predefined templates for
analysis
so just like dave showed today the the
max par
immune profiling assay template that he
brought up
that sort of template is going to be
able to be downloaded from the de novo
software website it's going to be able
to be downloaded from the fluidim
website
and essentially what will happen there
is you'll have some predefined gating
positions
and you have predefined gates for as
many gates as you want
and when you load the data in all of
that part of it will be done
we won't adjust those gates to you know
say the 90th percentile of data or
something like that
um so you do have to go through and
review gates you know you do have to
make sure
um that the gates are in the correct
positions but when you get them
in the correct positions you know we can
save that in fcs express you can use
that
from sample to sample we also have some
nice functionality in the software where
if you kind of have a a group of data
that all needs to be gated in the same
way
you can save kind of predefined gating
positions so as you move from one group
of data to another
um you know even though it's not being
automatically gated
you know by some sort of artificial
intelligence or something like that
predefined gating positions are allowed
and it should make things pretty
straightforward
for for doing any sort of analysis
awesome well thank you so much son for
your time today and we really appreciate
you being with us
that's no problem and thanks again for
everybody to uh come out and join in the
summit today it's been a lot of fun to
watch the presentations we really
appreciate you coming out today too
it has well before we go i'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand through july
of 2021 until next time goodbye